do nude scenes automatically Propel you
to higher levels of stardom the answer
is complicated and Alexander Dario knows
the answer better than most though she
had some minor appearances in a few
movies and TV shows in the early 2000s
Alexander daario's Big Break came when
she was cast in the 2010 film adaptation
of Rick roden's Percy Jackson and the
Olympians the Lightning Thief her name
Annabeth daughter of Athena the goddess
of wisdom sadly the film and its 2013
sequel Percy Jackson SE monsters were
criticized for being too similar to the
Harry Potter films while not being quite
as interesting besides sharing a
director in Chris Columbus they also
feature a trio of teenagers two boys and
one girl encountering magic in alternate
worlds no way yes way in an interview
with InStyle in 2023 tario revealed that
despite Landing a huge Blockbuster
franchise she wasn't ready to rest on
her Laurels she said I'm very very proud
of what I've accomplished and I'm
grateful but it's a ladder it wasn't
long long until the Dario's resume
diverged from the Teen fantasy where she
started out appearing in horror films
like malevolence 2 bereavement and Texas
Chainsaw she even made a guest
appearance on fx's It's Always Sunny in
Philadelphia which was a role she drove
4 hours overnight from Las Vegas to Los
Angeles to audition for since she's a
self-proclaimed huge fan of the show in
2013 didario was announced as a cast
member on HBO's new Anthology series
True Detective The Season's cast
included veterans like Matthew mccon
Woody harelson and Michelle Monahan
although didar had shared the screen
with numerous aist stars in the past she
felt some pressure when she joined the
HBO series she told Esquire I always
have a bit of trepidation before I start
anything just because I want to do well
you want to do a great job and you want
to impress people however she also kept
her expectations in check during the
filming of this inaugural season didario
wasn't sure if the show was even going
to be well received let alone go down in
TV history as one of the best seasons of
any show ever so she just treated the
role the same as any other job she
didn't become close with any of the cast
either being that she wasn't onset much
due to her limited role thankfully this
didn't harm her overall experience as
she explained to Esquire having dinner
with somebody you've looked up to your
whole life is quite a memorable thing
while daario's True Detective character
plays an integral role in the downfall
of Woody haralson's character many fans
of the show remember her performance for
a much less sophisticated reason in
episode 2 haralson's Marty Hart visits
Lisa's house in the two have sex
shattering the audience's view of heart
as a family man with strict morals in
this scene tario Bears it as she
seductively undresses herself for a
handcuffed heart I thought I was going
to put these on you you want
this yeah despite the scene's explicit
nature the Dario still felt it was
justified within the context of the
story and was mostly just happy to be
playing a role that was so different
from anything else she had done she also
credited scene partner Woody harelson
with making her feel comfortable which
she at other times described as
nerve-wracking unsurprisingly the scene
generated a lot of attention on the
internet which stario found flattering
despite being something she actively
tries to ignore although she has no
regrets about the scene did Dario
confess to Men's Journal I think that I
hadn't been that aware of my sex appeal
prior to that it can be negative some of
the attention and so I tried to ignore
some of the more negative aspects of it
despite the critical success of True
Detective the Show's first season was
criticized for its portrayal of women
particularly one article for the New
Yorker cited Alexander Dario's character
as an example of the show's gratuitous
nudity and accus the showrunners of
featuring underwritten female characters
who reveal more of their physical body
than of their personalities in an
interview with The Daily Beast didario
rejected these claims of True Detective
being misogynistic saying I feel like
the story was about these two flawed men
and the women especially my character
and Lily Simmons character were there to
propel their story lines forward she
further explained that she and the other
women on the show also experienced a
surge of interest from Hollywood after
their appearances which gave them more
power in Show Biz rather than less
didario talked about this effect in an
interview with collider recalling a
phone call with her manager the day
after her episode dropped she said I was
was sitting on my boyfriend's couch and
she calls me in the morning after the
episode aired and she was like the phone
won't stop ringing and all of a sudden
everyone in town wanted to meet with me
she continued to particularly credit her
work on True Detective for creating a
massive upswing in the opportunities she
was offered in Hollywood and found
herself auditioning for more adult
Centric films in fact weeks after her
risque appearance on True Detective she
was cast as one of the leads in the 2015
action movie s Andreas starring Dwayne
The Rock Johnson we're not high
enough get no while she felt distant
from the True Detective season 1 cast
she spoke highly of working with the
rock and The Rock felt the same about
her the two of them worked together
again not long after their first
collaboration this second outing
together occurred in 2017 with Baywatch
a film adaptation of the iconic
television series in the film tario
portrays summer Quinn the role
originally held by Nicole edgert in the
TV show true to the nature of a project
like Baywatch this role wouldn't exactly
stray from Daria's previous experience
of getting a lot of attention for her
body I'll be it for different reasons
while the R-rated film didn't feature
any nudity from the actress she still
had to put in a lot of work to maintain
a more athletic physique for the film
speaking to Women's Health about her
preparation for Baywatch didario said I
started doing weight training which I
had never done before and I saw a huge
difference it was kind of amazing the
transformation I went through while
Baywatch seemed to come naturally after
the success didario achieved with True
Detective the film itself was a critical
failure and a commercial
disappointment
don't you do this unsurprisingly bayat
garnered accusations of sexism and
objectification similar to those
directed at True Detective with rolling
stone writing in their two star review
that the film's female actors are quote
left trying to fight their way out of
various babe stereotypes did you just uh
look at my boobs I was not my intention
I didn't uh stare directly at them
you're looking at them right now this
wasn't the only subsequent project that
required her to flaunt her body also in
2017 didario co-star with K Upton in the
layover in which they play roommates
vying for the attention of an attractive
seatmate after their vacation flight is
rerouted due to a hurricane at the time
didario spoke highly of the film's
female Centric story and also felt like
she was getting used to being considered
sexy she told collider it wasn't
something that I tried to do so I
embrace it to a certain extent years
later tari reflected on this era in her
career and wondered if her choice of
projects had maybe led her aray by the
time the covid-19 pandemic hit the darer
started to feel like her career had hit
a wall and found herself this satisfied
with the project she was offered which
included several directed video on
demand releases such as can you keep a
secret and we summ in the darkness in
2019 all told it wasn't until 2020 that
she captured the attention of film
critics once again Lost Girls In Love
hotels features Daario in a starring
role is Margaret an American teacher
living in Tokyo who enters into a
romance with a member of the Yakuza the
role features Daario acting nude for the
first time since her Infamous True
Detective scene the movie itself
received mixed reviews with some
criticizing its meaningless story and
others praising its dark tone however
some reviewers praise the Dario's
performance with film Hound's writing
she quite possibly delivers her best
performance to date it's solely because
of her that the movie just about
succeeds other reviews praised the
Dario's compelling and thoughtful
contributions to the character of
Margaret even when they had few good
things to say about the rest of the film
although Lost Girls In Love hotels was
still taking advantage of Dario's looks
and willingness to Bear it all for the
plot it signaled the beginning of a
change she hadn't experienced since True
Detective where this time around the
attention was more on her acting than
her Anatomy while didario felt like her
career was stagnating post bayat the
entire entertainment industry went on
pause when the covid-19 pandemic shut
down Productions across the globe like
many other celebrities tario took this
opportunity to reach out to her audience
and began posting Vlogs on YouTube
featuring herself her roommates and
their various quarantine activities
although there was still media attention
surrounding Dario's body based on some
of these videos didario certainly seemed
in on the joke with several instances of
her openly mocking people's obsession
with her looks in one video going
through her wardrobe Dario jokingly
referenced her True Detective past I see
you're Googling surprisingly didario
remains active with her vlogging albeit
not as active as she was during the
height of lockdown her most recent video
was uploaded in September
2023 after many years of trying to
recapture the success she found on True
Detective in the film world didario
found herself joining another Anthology
series on HBO in 2021 with the White
Lotus which centers on the various
employees and guests of a fictional
Resort and their intertwining narratives
in the season one ensom didario plays
Rachel a newly wed on her honeymoon who
starts to second guess whether marrying
Jake Lacy's character an unfathomable
jerk was a good idea maybe I should call
my mother do you want to call your
mother what do you think she'll say I
think she's going to say we're in the
wrong room the first season premiered to
critical Acclaim and garnered a whole
bunch of Emmy nominations with the Dario
netting one for outstanding supporting
actress in a limited series or Anthology
which she lost to co-star Jennifer
kulich as a whole fans responded
positively to D ious performance is
Rachel who we can safely say is more
nuanced and relatable than her character
and True Detective as the Dario told The
Hollywood Reporter the role came at a
point in her career where she felt like
she was lacking Direction and Drew upon
that in her performance saying like my
character there have definitely been
times I felt misunderstood or not
breaking through and I feel like I took
it all somewhat in stride with critical
approval and Nei nomination behind her
D's future was entirely up to her now
although Alexandra didario has spoken
positively about her experience acting
in the nude unre detective in the past
few years there's been a reckoning of
how scenes like that are handled in
Hollywood after the discourse that
surrounded her and fellow co-stars nude
scenes on the HBO show it makes sense
that didario would be in support of an
entertainment industry that treated
women with more respect she suggested as
much when it comes to intimacy
coordinators who were officially
recognized in the renegotiated contracts
of zag after following the 2023 strikes
intimacy coordinators are defined as
individuals on set who choreograph and
monitor nude or sex scenes to make sure
actors are comfortable and safe as the
DAR omitted to InStyle she's all for the
changes just saying I think it was such
a long time coming that these things had
to happen and even if some people feel
like it's sort of an overcorrection I
think it's much better than not doing
anything about it the past few years
have seen Alexander didario transform
from an off forgotten actress who once
undressed for HBO to one of the most
promising and talented television stars
in the current media landscape while her
success will always be partially owed to
the attention she got from True
Detective it's clear that didario was
much prouder to be recognized for her
hard work and commitment to projects and
not simply how she looks with no clothes
on this is all on display into Dario's
most recent television Venture starring
an AMC's adaptation of Anne Rice's
Mayfair witches playing the role of Dr
Rowan Fielding a woman who discovers her
connection to a dynasty of witches was
one of the biggest challenges D Dario
has ever faced she told the AV club I
had never been the lead of my own TV
show which felt cool I'm looking for
anything instinctually right at the
moment and this did it for me
considering her experience adapting
books to screen with the Percy Jackson
films her Nate ability to capture the
audience's attention in True Detective
and her skills at connect with audiences
thanks to the White Lotus Mayfair
witches seems like the perfect
amalgamation of all she's worked towards
the question now is why did it have to
take so
long